fred vargas et le beau pseudonyme sonore
d'une femme écrivain auteur d'une demi
douzaine de romans policiers remarquent
et est publié chez viviane hamy avec
l'homme à l'envers qui vient de paraître
elle nous transporte dans l'arrière-pays
niçois au coeur du massif du mercantour
deux hommes sont allongés dans la
broussaille
je mets à la main il est 10 heures du
matin et déjà le soleil cogne
il observe un couple de loups ce sont
des spécialistes de ces animaux pendant
ce temps là à paris le commissaire
adamsberg rentrer tard chez lui regarde
les nouvelles à la télévision dans les
alpes-maritimes précisément loups de
taille gigantesque égorge les moutons et
terrorisent les populations
l'émotion gronde la colère couve chez
les éleveurs il est question d'une
battue monstre dans le village les
caractères étonnant ne manquent pas à
commencer par cette suzanne rosselin qui
dirige seul son élevage à l'écart des
autres
assisté de son fils adoptif solim en
l'afrique autre caractère camille une
femme compositeur qui gagne sa vie en
faisant de la plomberie
elle a été très proche de dams berg
autrefois non moins originale massart le
gars des abattoirs un type qui n'a pas
de poils du tout ou plutôt il a les
poils tourné vers l'intérieur
c'est un homme à l'envers un loup garou
et ne voilà-t-il pas qu'un beau matin
suzanne rosselin et découverte égorgée